you don't think one woman's enough for
for a man I know you mentioned that
earlier me yeah uh well I don't I think
one woman is enough but I think that men
always have a natural instinct to want
to have other girls so if he doesn't
exercise that option he's fighting
against his biology so I feel like one
woman he can he can suppress it but like
it's always in his mind that he wants to
up it depends what she's giving as
well I feel like men need that sexual
fulfillment the way women need the
immers
right women need their men to be there
for them in certain ways but if women
are willing to reciprocate that in the
form of sexual gratification then is
definitely going to have a wondering eye
and you can't blame anybody but yourself